[MUSIC PLAYING]
MANJOT PAHWA: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Welcome to the Kubernetes Engine
enterprise-ready networking
session.
Today, I will talk
to you about why
Kubernetes Engine is
the choice of platform
for enterprise workloads.
So a little bit of recap.
Kubernetes Engine went
generally available in 2015.
And Kubernetes was
born in the Cloud.
It was always a very
developer-friendly environment.
And also, the choice of
platform for Cloud-native.
What does that mean?
Cloud-native cares
about a lot of things
like developer agility,
automation, and also having
a great experience.
Enterprises-- they care about
all of that and a lot more.
Today, I will mention
how Kubernetes Engine has
gone through that
journey of also becoming
the choice of platform
for enterprise workloads.
Now let's talk about,
what does it actually
mean to be enterprise-ready?
So in front of you
are the four pillars
of enterprise readiness,
comprising of the first one
being deployment simplicity.
Deployment simplicity is being
able to control, and manage,
and scale all your cluster
resources seamlessly
with enough control.
Fine-grained control.
Typically, an
enterprise would want
to isolate their
critical network
resources from your
non-critical ones,
but still have the flexibility
given to our project admins
to create and manage clusters.
And I'll talk about how
Kubernetes Engine helps
you get that.
The third being security.
Security is a very important
pillar for all enterprises.
I will talk how
Kubernetes Engine ensures
that all your request spots--
whether it's within
your VPC, whether it's
to and from the internet, or
connecting to other Google
services-- are secure.
And last but not
least, visibility.
Of course, it is very
important for enterprises
to be able to see what is
going on within their network
and anticipate how exactly
Kubernetes Engine helps
you get that
visibility, which is
so crucial to your deployments.
And how all these four
pillars work together
to give a unified experience.
Now I welcome to
stage Brad, who's
a lead system architect
from Symphony,
to talk about his
journey with us.
[APPLAUSE]
BRAD DIETRICH:
Thank you, Manjot.
So just to give you a little
bit of an idea of what
we experience and
who we are, Symphony
is a secure messaging platform,
a secure collaboration platform
really aimed at very,
very secure and--
financial services
industry, primarily.
So we spend a lot
of our time talking
to some of the most security
sensitive enterprises
that are on the planet.
So from an enterprise-readiness
perspective, we certainly--
even though we,
ourselves, are a startup--
we experience that
enterprise-readiness
need very succinctly.
The set of customers
that we deal with
are cautious of public internet.
They want the
Cloud-native features
that Manjot mentioned--
the ability to be agile.
The ability to be more nimble
and less locally expensive.
They're running a lot of their
workloads on-premise today,
but they want to move
them to the Cloud for all
the same reasons that any of
the consumer facing applications
have moved to the Cloud.
But they are cautious and
concerned about the security.
And so functionally, as
we went through this,
we started working very
closely with the GKE team
to become Cloud-native to
bring that Cloud-nativeness
into these enterprises.
From our perspective, the
problem with Cloud-nativeness
was primarily driven around
getting the traditional way
of thinking about
networking solved in a way
that we don't have the
internet as the problem, which
is exactly the opposite of
what the Cloud is, of course.
Because the Cloud is
right on the internet.
Everybody knows the
internet's between it
and the actual
users of the work.
So functionally, private
clusters-- very important
feature for us.
We worked very closely
with Manjot and her team
to get private clusters
accelerated to the point
where we can start to use them.
Keeping all the IP addressing
in a private space on the VPC.
None of it ever exposed out
into the public internet,
making the enterprise very
comfortable with the fact
that they understood where their
traffic patterns were flowing.
And they didn't have
problems likely to be
affected by even the things
we've seen in the news
recently.
Like BGP routing
attacks or other things,
where public internet
would have been a problem.
So now our enterprises,
our largest customers,
they don't connect--
even though,
they use either a direct connect
into the Cloud or they use
a VPN connection that they
trust very succinctly--
communicating only
over private IPs,
allowing for that
secure platform
that we built to be
deployed in a Cloud-native
and our customers to consume it.
So we really do believe
that these features are
really important
to making it happen
in an enterprise-ready fashion.
And we hope that
your enterprises
will start to adopt some
of these features, as well.
With Google being, kind
of, leading the charge
on Kubernetes.
And I think next,
Mahesh is going
to come up and speak
a little bit more.
MAHESH NARAYANAN:
Thanks a lot, Brad.
That was pretty interesting.
Thanks for tying up how
Kubernetes Engine provides
features that meets
your requirement.
Good morning, everyone.
My name is Mahesh Narayanan.
I'm a product manager in
Cloud networking team,
working on GKE.
Well, just a reprise of
what we talked about,
the four pillars--
deployment simplicity,
fine-grained control,
security, and visibility--
but there are so many of us,
when we try a new platform,
we find that it
misses or does not
have certain key
fundamental features.
And our reaction is, what
do you mean it doesn't work?
I can do that today on
my current platform.
Well, our hope is during the
course of this discussion,
we will show to you how
Kubernetes Engine is
a great platform for
enterprise deployment
and help avoid this
reaction from you.
We have a mixed
crowd so before we
get into the different aspects
of what enterprise-readiness
means, let's talk
about certain building
blocks of Kubernetes Engine.
These building
blocks will be used
to explain other
topics in the section
so it will be useful over
the next 40 minutes, as well.
We all know about
Virtual Private Cloud.
This is the building
block of GCP networking.
A Virtual Private
Cloud in GCP provides
a global, fully meshed,
and a private IP network.
This is, in fact, the
customers' networks
lies in the GCP network.
Within a VPC, we have
subnetworks which provides
regional boundaries with a VPC.
And they give a
location connotation.
These two are the fundamental
building blocks of GCP,
whether you're doing GCP,
or GKE, or GCE, or anything
of that sort.
Kubernetes Engine adds a
few more networking elements
to the mix.
Let's talk about those.
First among them is the
Kubernetes Engine cluster.
A cluster consists of
nodes, parts, and services.
A cluster also has
a cluster master
which is the brains behind
controlling the cluster.
It provides the control
plane functionality
to manage the cluster.
A VPC can have
multiple clusters.
Nodes are VM instances
on which pods are run.
The nodes compute networking
and storage resources
to the different pods.
Depending upon the pod's
resource constraints,
you can have nodes
of different sizes.
The node gets an IP and
it's routable by default.
Pods, think of them as tiny
task-specific processes
that are running on
top of your nodes.
A pod gets an IP
automatically and is also
routable by default. A pod can
run one container or multiple
containers, such as
a docker container.
And when there are
multiple containers running
on top of a pod, all of them
are managed as a single entity,
sharing the
resources of the pod.
Services.
A service is something that
is long-lived and provides
a stable and a fixed end point
to represent all your pods.
A pod, on the other
hand, is ephemeral.
It can come and go because
of failures or scalability.
So pods are ephemeral.
Services are long-lived.
Services basically provide an
abstraction for all your pods.
A good example for services
is a load balancer.
All this come together in
a flat networking model
where VPC is the underlying
glue that provides
a fully meshed network.
And in this fully
meshed network,
all the nodes can
talk to each other.
All the parts can
And all the nodes and parts can
talk to each other, by default.
The benefits of this
model become more obvious
in the next few sections.
Deployment simplicity.
So one size doesn't fit all
and this is especially true
for enterprise networking
that has evolved over time.
So Kubernetes Engine has an
interesting challenge at hand.
For deployment
simplicity, it needs
to ensure that it's
providing the best
practices in networking
and enterprise networking,
especially.
And at the same
time, integrate well
with an enterprises' on-prem,
as well as Cloud presence.
So let's talk about what
are the different aspects
within deployment simplicity.
One is control.
First and foremost, customers
do not like surprises.
They want tight control
over all their resources.
One way Kubernetes
Engine delivers
this is by having
distinct ranges
for the different resources.
So if corporate has a
policy, manage a policy
where they see the notion
not talk to each other,
but the pods should be able
to talk to each other--
by having distinct ranges for
nodes, pods, and services,
it makes it a more
intuitive model for you
to apply such a policy.
You can use a firewall
policy to block the nodes
and that pods, by default,
are talking to each other.
This is a much simpler model
to implement in your network.
Control is also
extended in the form
of provisioning flexibility.
If you're an
enterprise customer who
has a very intricate
deployment scheme,
you can either let us
decide the addresses for you
these address engine for you.
Or you also have the
user-defined option.
And the user-defined option
is very critical for, again,
for the customers who have
a very intricate scheme.
Just as how you are
define an IP in a VPC
and you map that to a
region through subnetworks,
you can create
custom subnetworks
and map the nodes,
pods, and services
in a particular region.
This gives you very
fine-grained control.
This makes the
cluster size fungible.
And also solves the
bin packing problem.
Forgot to animate this.
So in this example, as you can
see, since these ranges are
different, the
nodes-- you can apply
a firewall policy or
a security policy,
which stops the node from
talking to each other,
but pods can talk to each other.
Centralized management.
As more customers start
deploying Kubernetes Engine,
we have seen that
one of the most
often asked questions
from customers
is around risk management.
For certain large-sized
enterprises,
IP addresses-- even
private IP addresses--
is a precious commodity.
They want to ensure that
the scheme that they land
on for addressing, makes
sense, works for them as they
scale out in future.
So Kubernetes Engine solves
this problem for the customer
by understanding
what is being used.
Where it is being used.
What is available.
And what is the min/max size
for the different resources.
Another advantage
of this model is
that we track the addresses
as you grow your cluster
across your cluster.
So with this tracking
and check, we
ensure that there is
no address collusion
as you grow more
resources in the cluster
or you grow-- even
your clusters-- you
grow into multiple clusters.
This tracking is done
dynamically and at runtime.
And it also shows that not
only is your GKE footprint
not getting address
collision, but even
your GCP footprint is not
getting any address collision.
So if you are building
something on GKE
and you're also using
certain elements on GCP--
let's say, a GCE
or internal load
balancer-- we ensure that there
is no collision across the two.
Integrated networking.
So when Kubernetes
was introduced,
there were multiple models
to implement and contain IP
connectivity.
Some implemented encapsulated
overlay networks.
There was network
route programming
for directing the
container traffic.
But in both these
models, the networking
was bolted onto the
Cloud infrastructure,
making it less
agile and coming up
with a list of features
that were [INAUDIBLE]..
With the launch of
VPC native clusters,
clusters and their
different resources
are now integrated within
the Google infrastructure.
All the clusters and
the different resources,
again, are first class
citizens within the VPC.
Now what that means is features
like shared VPC, VPC peering,
access to Google services,
all are available by default
to your GKE applications
running on a Kubernetes Engine.
As an example, if
you're using pods
and you are accessing
these services--
Cloud Storage,
Cloud with table--
over a public IP,
with VPC native,
you can now access
these services
over the pods
private IP, as well.
It's seamless.
Lastly, hybrid support.
No Kubernetes
Engine deployment is
complete without providing
support for hybrid networking.
We want to ensure that for
easy onboarding of Kubernetes
Engine, the mechanisms
that exist today to make
on-prem pop to Cloud,
work seamlessly
for Kubernetes Engine, as well.
So with that in mind,
Kubernetes Engine clusters
are transparent to on-prem.
We have the concept
of Cloud routers
which facilitates the
communication between on-prem
and GKE clusters seamlessly.
You can use the existing
VPN mechanism, whether that
is Cloud VPN or dedicated
interconnect or partner
interconnect, and
connect from your on-prem
to the Kubernetes clusters.
You can also have
very tight control
over what gets to talk to whom.
So if you want to ensure
that from on-prem,
only certain
applications or pods
are available to
communicate with, again,
from the help of Cloud
router and using routing,
you can advertise specific
subnets between the on-prem
and the Cloud.
With that, I'll hand
it over to Manjot.
Thank you.
MANJOT PAHWA: Thank
you so much, Mahesh.
Now I will talk about security.
You all have a tough job.
Security is one of those
things which is never enough.
And we at GKE, believe in having
both belts and suspenders.
And now I will
talk about how GKE
tries to ensure that all
your surface areas of attack
are covered.
We at GKE, believe in a
layered security model
where we cover every aspect and
every layer of your deployment
that should be secure.
Broadly dividing it into config
time and runtime security,
where config time
consists of separation
of administrative control
for your deployments.
And runtime consists
of private deployments
and network security.
Now, separation of
administrative control,
what it enables you
to do is, typically,
you would have an organization
with an infrastructure
and a platform team,
which would want
to control your critical
network resources
and still have your
app or your front end
teams be able to create and
manage their GKE clusters.
And runtime security-- private
deployment enables you to get
network segmentation where
your back end services--
which shouldn't be
exposed on the internet--
are not.
And network security
dives a layer
deeper from private
deployments and drills
down within your
cluster to enable
you to control your
interservice communication.
Shared VPC.
I will pick up the
first one, which
was a separation of
administrative controls.
So shared VPC enables you to
map your organizational topology
onto your critical
network resources.
And how does it actually
allow you to do that?
So Kubernetes solved
the problem of enabling
you to write your
infrastructure as code,
but we need to still reconcile
your operational security
models with that.
And what shared VPC does is it
enables your critical network
resources-- such as firewalls
and other such resources--
to be controlled by a handful
of network and security admins.
And your project or
your cluster admins
still have the ability to
be able to create clusters
within a shared
network and not have
to deal with things like
network and security
critical resources.
Developers should be able
to code, test, and deploy
their applications without
having to deal with questions
of connectivity or
firewalls and shared
VPC enables you to do that.
So talking about, what
are the benefits that
shared VPC actually gives you--
first thing that I've
already mentioned
is the separation of your
security and your project admin
roles.
So typically, in a deployment
or an organization,
you will have your
infrastructure teams
and your platform teams
controlling those network
resources.
And have your project
teams or application teams,
being able to create and deploy
clusters in the shared subnets,
without having the ability
to change those resources.
And that gives you
separation of rules.
Second, sharing of
common resources.
Isolation is great, but in
deployments, you certainly
have some resources that
you would like to share
across all those clusters.
And shared VPC enables
you to still do
that and have that
isolation that you require.
Third, isolation of data
and support for multi-tenant
workloads.
By dividing your
workloads and your teams
into separate projects that
you can attach to your larger
project or your
organizational host project,
you get isolation of
data so as to prevent
deliberate or inadvertent
attacks that you might get.
And fourth, more
granular billing.
We often hear enterprises
wanting more granular billing
on a team basis.
And by dividing your
organization into those teams
and mapping those
teams to projects
that work in a shared VPC model,
you get more granular billing.
Let's look under the hood.
I think this is too
fuzzy [INAUDIBLE]..
So you have your
organization and then
you have your host project.
Your host project consists
of your shared VPC network,
which consists of a few subnets
and all the critical network
resources that you
want to control.
Then you have your
different apps teams.
You have your apps project.
You have a database,
infrastructure,
and many other
teams that you might
have in your organization.
And what you do is you map
all of them to what we call,
service projects.
And you attach all those service
projects to your host project.
This way, using IAM
permissions, you
give permissions to our
project or your team admins
to be able to create
and manage clusters
within the boundaries
of their project,
without affecting
any other team.
And you enable the network
and security admins
to be able to control
the critical network
resources that you don't want
the project admins affecting.
And so this enables
each and every team
to work independently
and with agility.
Moving on to the
second pillar and this
comes under runtime security--
private deployments.
Private deployments is a
very, very crucial factor
for a lot of enterprises.
A lot of enterprises want to
ensure that their Kubernetes
Engine deployments are
within the secure boundary
of their VPC.
Typically, you have a
multi-tiered application.
You have a few front
end apps and you have
a lot of back end services.
And your back end services--
which are not exposed
to the internet and don't
require public IPs--
shouldn't have them.
And private clusters
enables you to do that.
Private clusters enables you to
cordon off your control plane
and to enable
network segmentation
by removing public
IPs from the nodes
and taking your workloads
off the public internet.
Second of all, with some
of the lot advancements
in our peering capabilities,
the communication
between your nodes and
the Kubernetes Master
is completely private.
And third, using
private clusters.
Using private clusters,
you can ensure
that you set your control
plane to default deny.
This way, only things
that you trust,
only the perimeter
that you trust
has access to your
GKE deployments.
And unauthorized access--
whether it's to your nodes
or to your control plane--
is completely blocked.
Master authorized networks.
Now, with private clusters,
you took your nodes
and your workloads off
the public internet,
but you want to
be able to manage
the access to your control plane
in a more fine-grain manner.
You definitely want to
block unauthorized access,
but there might be
some trusted set of IPs
that you still
want to have access
to your Kubernetes Master.
So master authorized
networks is the option
to set a white-list
on your [INAUDIBLE]
to have access from their
trusted set of IPs, which
maybe on your
premise or elsewhere
and can control your deployment.
So moving on to network security
and drilling down to clusters.
So private deployments ensures
that your clusters are secure.
Network policy works
within a single cluster.
Network security
with network policies
ensures that in a model where
you have multiple services
within your single
cluster, they are
secure by being segmented
from each other.
So let's say, you have some
vulnerability which affected
the front end services.
We want to ensure that
your front end services are
compromised, but then, they
don't affect critical services,
like billing.
And network policies
enable you to do that.
Network policies are
user-defined policies
that you set on your
deployment, which
get enforced in real-time.
And Kubernetes Engine ensures
that the network policy
that you control are enforced
in real-time and to the scale
that Kubernetes Engine supports.
Now, let me sum up all of the
things that I've mentioned
and give you an overview
of how we see security.
Broadly dividing into config
time and runtime, where
you get separation of
administrative control
so that you can map your
organizational topology
to your network, is using shared
VPC with granular IAM rules.
So that you can ensure
that your project
admins create
clusters, but do not
affect those critical
network resources.
Runtime security consisting
of, first of all,
private deployments, which
Brad had spoken about earlier.
Private clusters enables you
to take off your clusters
from the public
internet and ensure
with master authorized
networks that your control
plane is cordoned off, and
gives access only to the trusted
set of IPs that you control.
Network security achieved
through the network policies,
which ensures that in a
microservices model where you
have multiple services
within your cluster,
you control exactly
which services
can talk to which
other services, instead
of the previous way of having
a network level firewall which
gives you an all or nothing.
Now, moving on to visibility.
Security is obviously,
an important aspect
of all your deployments.
And having visibility into what
is going on within your network
is equally important.
I will show you how some
of the things that we
are launching at Kubernetes
Engine help you do that.
So logging and monitoring
are the cornerstones
of your deployments
and Kubernetes Engine
ensures that you have enough
visibility and flexibility
to get information about the
traffic flow within your VPC.
And VPC flow logs
enables you to do that.
VPC flow logs captures
the traffic flow,
whether its within your VPC.
Whether it's to and
from the internet.
Or whether it's from your
on-premises to your deployment.
Or if you're using a
host of Google services.
So VPC flow logs ensures that
it captures all the traffic
flows that are there within
your deployment, which
you might want to look
into for several reasons.
VPC flow logs also had to
optimize your network usage
and egress, enabling
you to better budget
for your deployments.
Now VPC flow logs
is a raw form of log
that you can use to
visualize with your choice
of visualization engine.
And we have integration
with a host of partners,
or you can use Stackdriver.
And VPC flow logs
also enables you
to get network forensics
and security analysis,
to dive deeper into any attacks
that you might have experience
or within your deployment.
And lastly, it also gives you
a real-time security analysis
with a five-second time.
VPC flow logs is also
flexible in the sense
that you can export
that information
in a very secure manner to
BigQuery or to Stackdriver
Logging-- as I
already mentioned.
Moreover, you might
have platforms
that you prefer to visualize
that log information.
And you can use Cloud
Pub/Sub to actually
export that information out and
visualize it the way you want.
This is a typical way in which
you can visualize information
from VPC flow logs,
where it captures
the flows that are there between
your nodes and your pods.
And you can see here, the
overall traffic that is flowing
through your deployment.
You can see things like is it
coming from central, or Europe,
or which zone or
region is coming from?
And you can also visualize
the busiest machines
that you might have.
Now, I will call
upon Bowei to give
a cool demo of some
of the features
that we just spoke about.
[APPLAUSE]
BOWEI DU: So hi.
Thanks, Manjot.
In this demo, we'll dig into how
a single application spread up
across multiple teams
and responsibilities
will map to shared VPC.
And really see how shared
VPC and private clusters
will work in practice
to secure your apps.
So suppose you have a
multi-tier application that
spans multiple teams.
In this example, you
have an apps team
responsible for the front
end, exposing the application
service to the internet.
You have an infra-team
who manages the back end.
Now for development agility
and finer-grained resource
accounting, you
would like each team
to be responsible for
their Kubernetes cluster,
but you have a net
ops team that's
responsible for the overall
security and network resource
management.
So the question
is, how would you
map this to Google Cloud
and Kubernetes Engine?
So first, we start
with the host project--
the VPC network, which is
owned by the net ops team.
They're responsible
for IP assignments.
Firewall, generally speaking.
Access and resource allocation.
And they have full control
over the networking
aspects of the host project.
Next, you have the apps team
and their service project.
And they will be managing
the front end application.
Also, they will be
managing your users
coming in from the internet
hitting the application.
Finally, you have
the infra-team.
And now, something to notice
is that this infra-team also
has an additional requirement.
They want to keep the nodes
in their Kubernetes cluster
completely private,
but also want
to be able to be accessible
from the application.
So let's dive in and see
what this looks like.
And whoops.
So we have this
set up from before.
So let's dive in and
see what the shared VPC
setup looks like in your
Google Cloud Project.
So as mentioned before, you
have a shared VPC host project
that will be owned
by the network admin.
In addition, you have
attached service projects
for each of the teams.
So you'll see an
attached service project
for the infra-team, an
for the apps team.
Now, let's zoom in
on the apps team
and what their
application looks like.
So for the apps team, they're
using Kubernetes Engine.
And let's take a look
at our application.
It's a pod running
on the cluster.
And the services is a
load balancer service,
but first, we need to open up
the firewall for this service.
When you're running in a
shared VPC environment,
you can create
these service, you
can expose them
as load balancer--
using standard Kubernetes
primitives-- but it's
up to the net ops team to
actually expose the firewall.
So let's do that.
So this will be done
by the net ops team.
They will receive a request say,
hey, I'm creating a service.
I want to put it
on the internet.
And it will be up
in the net ops team
to expose the service, which
is these two firewalls.
That then will expose
the Kubernetes service
to the internet users.
So we open the
firewall, what next?
Let's zoom in on the infra-team.
So the infra-team is
managing a back end,
serving database and other data.
Now, first of all,
it's a private cluster
so actually, you can't access
it directly from the internet
as you can with
a normal cluster.
And you will have
to use the bastion
host to access the cluster.
In the infra-side, you have an
application running as a pod.
And you will also
need to open up
a firewall between
the apps and the DB.
They're part of the same
VPC so they're connectable,
but you'll have to do some
work to open the firewall so
that these two can communicate.
And as you see here, the net ops
team will be in charge of this.
And they will open an
apps to back end firewall.
Finally, let's see these
two pieces in concert.
So we have the application
front end on the right side.
We have the infrastructure
back end on the left side.
And here is our application.
So our application
is very simple.
It says, hello next 2018.
But as you can see, it
comes in from the internet,
hits the app.
The app then queries the
back end inside the VPC
in a secure way and the reply
goes out back to the user.
So throughout this
presentation, we've
seen what it means
for Kubernetes Engine
to be a great platform
for enterprise workloads.
Now I want you to take away four
things from this presentation.
First, is that Kubernetes
Engine gives you
deployment simplicity.
So it gives you the tools to
control, manage, and scale
your cluster resources
in a centralized manner.
And your clusters will
integrate seamlessly
with other GCP resources.
Basically, everything is
connected and part of one VPC.
And as you could
see in the demo,
you have multiple teams
and they all share one VPC
and you can create
applications that
span multiple teams,
multiple projects,
but use the same network.
Second, we get
fine-grained control
and shared VPC enables
you a separation
of administrative roles so
that your network resources are
managed by network
ops, without hampering
the productivity of your other
teams in creating clusters.
You get security.
So with Kubernetes Engine, you
can make every path and surface
area secure with
private clusters
and master authorized networks.
And finally, visibility
with VPC flow
logs, you get views into all
of the flows in your deployment
and your VPC.
And the one thing I want you to
take away is that all of this
is integrated in an
unified experience for all
of your workloads.
So thank you for
coming to our session
and now we will have the Q&A.
[MUSIC PLAYING]